du soleil la mer des palmiers des stars
bienvenue à cannes à cannes il ya aussi
des jeunes comédiens à l'honneur 20
d'entre eux ont été sélectionnés pour
faire partie de l'opération talents à
d'amicale une opération pour promouvoir
le talent de ces futures stars et parmi
les sélectionnés cette année à marc karm
el habib ur originaire de sartrouville
elle a été diplômée de l'école
supérieure d'art dramatique de la ville
de paris puis elle a intégré la comédie
française et on la retrouve ici à cannes
à la fiche du court métrage merci
monsieur imada de sylvain chaumet 1 aux
tribunes loi dont on vous parlera plus
tard
oh
l'histoire est simple ce sont quatre
comédiens jeunes comédiens qui n'ont pas
une expérience très développé dans le
cinéma
quatre jeunes comédiens qui passe une
audition pour un réalisateur très très
connu monsieur et madame c'est un court
métrage sur le métier sûr
sur les jeunes comédiens sur le tournage
comment se déroule un tournage et c'est
une comédie très cynique aussi on rit on
grince des dents et on est ému en même
temps un sur un première déjà le court
métrage en lui-même il me plaît beaucoup
donc je suis assez fier de montrer ce
travail là après ça serait mentir que de
dire que je m'en moque des retombées
tout ça non j'espère j'espère faire un
peu plus d'image comme je le disais et
puis c'est vrai que plus on travaille
plus on est vu plus on donne peut-être
envie à des réalisateurs des metteurs en
scène de travailler avec nous donc
donc voilà je vous le disais armelle
habibou est originaire de sartrouville
et bien c'est à sartrouville est
également que l'on a rencontré charlotte
marcos une jeune femme de 32 ans prof
d'anglais et qui vient de réaliser son
premier court métrage une trentaine de
personnes l'ont épaulé dans son projet
un projet qu'elle a payé en partie grâce
à un site de financement participatif
le résultat est plutôt bluffant voici
johnny and cash
c'est l'histoire de johnny car loser qui
vit que sur pour sa belle mustang et un
jour il fait des réparations sur sa
voiture mais n'a pas l'argent pour payer
pour rembourser sa dette il bosse pour
un boss mafieux
sauf que sa première mission vire au
drame et est-ce que poursuivre par trois
malfrats no1 en apprentissage ici pour
moi comment je pouvais savoir tu es un
mec qui avait volé l'argent tu comprends
pas que ce boss va faire la peau faucon
qui te dis ouais
son homélie gégé a pris effectivement
principalement regardant des films en
regardant des making of en voyant
comment il faisait et
j'essayais de faire un petit peu mon
style à moi même si ce sera comme très
inspiré des films de tarantino ça se
verra
et on se quitte avec notre star du jour
c'est un acteur né en 1978 il a donc 38
ans il a grandi à trappes dans les
yvelines
et s'il a raté son bac c'est parce qu'il
a suivi jamel debbouze à cannes l'année
de l'examen on l'a vu à la télévision
dans le sav des émissions puis au cinéma
dans intouchables
il s'agit vous l'aurez forcément deviner
d'omar sy l'acteur qui prête sa voix à
un personnage de film d'animation angry
birds un film actuellement dans les
salles dont il est venu assurer la
promotion ici à cannes
sa lutte et le fil 78 dans tout groupe
civilisé il y à un paria
dès son plus jeune âge le paria a du mal
à s'intégrer
peut parfois se sentir invisible et
souvent ils peinent à se faire des amis
mais malgré toutes ces difficultés le
paria persiste à vouloir tisser des
liens
cannes soit 118 c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui n'oubliez pas comme le dit
fabrice luchini le cinéma c'est une
parenthèse enchantée
non